[Music]
actress January Jones from Mad Men just
came out with a new PSA in which she
calls for the protection of the great
white shark
let's take a look healthy oceans meet
sharks but great whites are in danger of
extinction we should be scared for great
whites please help before it's too late
ok I had no problem at all with January
Jones great white PSA I just wish it
hadn't come out on the same day as my
new public service announcement a lot of
people are afraid of Cobras but I think
we should be afraid for Cobras are they
in danger no their populations
flourishing there are estimated be over
60 million Cobras worldwide are they
harmless well no they're not one bite
from a Cobra contains enough venom to
bring down a bull elephant so why should
we care about them because Cobras are by
far the coolest looking snakes around
Plus nearly 98% of them are gainfully
employed as dancers at Indian Bar
Mitzvahs that's why I'm encouraging all
celebrities to do what I did get a wild
Cobra and keep it as a pet hey Conan
what's in the basket
Andy skin
you're gonna die
[Applause]
[Music]
what idiot walks up with this what's in
the back when you want to be
interrupting the filming of a PSA how
rude of me
I deserve that light in the eye you're
the only adult I know who can become a
four-year-old like that